this morning we're going to start here
with star trek's william shatner as
you've heard going
where no 90 year old man has ever gone
before a 90 year old woman either for
that matter the actor best known as
captain kirk will be on the second crude
rocket mission for jeff bezos blue
origin company with three other
passengers shatner will become the
oldest person ever to fly into space
mark straussman is covering the launch
from blue origin spaceport in west texas
mark before he left he told us he was
anxious he was excited he was little
nervous
he's all those things gail and good
morning it must be hard for william
shatner to believe this moment has
finally come i mean after all these
years he's finally about to become
captain kirk and go to space and so here
on this massive ranch that jeff bezos
owns he'll launch about three miles
behind me later this morning and fly to
the edge of space
and back
i'm going up into space
i don't know how many people can say
that
at 90 william shatner has lived long
jeff bezos has prospered together
they'll turn star trek into reality
launching shatner warp speed to the edge
of space total up and down trip time
about 10 minutes
[Music]
55 years after shatner's captain james t
kirk first defined star voyaging on
television and it looks like there's a
great deal of curiosity
about this fictional character
captain kirk going into space so let's
go along with it and enjoy the ride
flying with shatner who was compt a
ticket by blue origin
to millionaire businessmen and a blue
origin executive and you're going to
hear the engine cut off they've trained
over the last two days for this moment
their space tourism adventure in blue
origin's new shepard crew capsule pause
here with me bill for a second
pausing to watch legions of star trek
fans they include professional
astronauts with childhood memories
traveling the cosmos with a starship
enterprise i watched star trek growing
up
you know so i think that's awesome like
the members of spacex crew 3 scheduled
to launch to the iss later this month
who wouldn't want to see william shatner
fly in space
like i don't know anybody who wouldn't
back in july millions watched bezos
launch himself into space
now it's captain kirk's turn not william
shatner's final frontier but his next
one i want to look at that orb and
appreciate its beauty and its
tenacity is sustaining this life
of ours
which allows us to look
with awe and wonder at the miracle of
space
by design including shatner on this
flight is a publicity bonanza for blue
origin the two businessmen flying with
him paid their own way but blue origin
has never disclosed the price of the
ticket but for the rest of us or at
least for most of us that price tag is
bound to be in the stratosphere
tony big moment for shatner big moment
for star trek fans all over
big moment for all of us i mean four
people are going up today but the bigger
mission is a future where millions of
people are living and working in space
and that means it's an exciting time to
be alive mark thank you very much